[Music]
all right people I am outside the
Republican debate here in my hometown of
Miami look at this I am officially a
debate attendee apparently I'll be in
the orchestra I'm going to play the tuba
we're very excited for what's going to
happen tonight of course Donald Trump is
not here he's in haia I think I
pronounced that right doing his own
thing tonight uh my guess is it's going
to get a little a little chippy cuz this
is is really the last chance for people
to make their case before the Iowa
situation uh obviously I think Rd is
going to do pretty well I think Nikki is
going to go heavy on what's going on in
the Middle East VC will most likely make
fun of everyone and then say we should
all be better and not make fun of each
other and Chris Christie's here too I
wonder what he had for dinner okay see
you in a
bit holy
cow that was me just an hour and a half
ago in Brickle which is the the city
part of Miami I'm in the suburb part I
left the debate early to get here so
that we could jump and get a little bit
ahead of some of the other post debate
shows uh we thought that would be a good
idea and uh you know unfortunately these
debates are not well they're not really
debates they're not the most inspiring
thing ever and uh we felt
yeah let's just leave early and get here
and do our thing here you are seeing
Dave Rubin very rarely in uh suit and
tie in the studio damn must I say myself
we may have to do this a little more
often uh that little cold open that we
showed you right there that was us
shooting right outside uh that was
probably about what 6:30 p.m. or so uh
before the debate and uh I'm pretty sure
I nailed exactly what was going to
happen Des santis was going to do just
fine Nikki was going to go very heavy on
the mid East stuff obviously VC was
going to insult everybody and then not
say you know basically say well why are
we insulting people and Christy okay
what did he have for dinner and then Tim
Scott I guess he he was there too uh
anyway we're just going to dive into
some of the clips as I said because I
was in the car uh for about 20 minutes I
missed that last 40 minutes or so so
some of this I will be doing completely
on the fly with you but I think you have
already what my general take is my
general take is that at this point in
Where We Are act in the world which is a
as the kids say a problematic Place uh
Donald Trump needed to be there we have
to have it out with all of these people
and if you love Donald Trump and you
think he's going to crush and all of
that stuff that's just fine but he
should be able to be up there defending
his ideas and it it didn't the thing is
he's doing something very clever at a at
a PR level at a strategy level cuz you
could feel it in that room it's like
they opened up with a question about
Trump which will get to in just a second
but you could feel it in the room it's
like everyone knows it's like H the guy
who most likely whether I like it or not
the guy who most likely will be the
nominee is not in that room and he's off
doing his uh his campaign thing and hi
alyah did I do it right did I say it
right that Leia hi Leia okay all right
I'm kind of new here too um and it just
it's like man is this just the ending of
the Republican party as we know it which
is why I often say I am not a national
Republican I am a Florida Republican and
those things are very different but he
should have been there he should have
been there with with everything going on
in the world like kening towards World
War II The Border biomics like all of
the stuff yeah he he owes it to you even
if even if you're not where I'm at in
terms of who you think the the candidate
should be like if you are the trumpi
Trump supporter in Trump town he owes it
to you I think anyway that's what I
think about that let's just dive right
into it though uh VC opened up strong
this is this is the we're going to show
you two clips right now this is the best
and worst oh wait before we do anything
else I should note we're in our uh
evening Studio here we added a couple
Tequila bottles and look at that we've
got blue neon lights those are normally
white but we thought they will be blue
for the evening my God it's a
[Laughter]
celebration what are we doing what are
we doing really I mean look whatever
we're going to do here I promise you
will'll be better than corporate press
there you go uh and we do have some
tequila bottles and we shifted a few uh
a few books and things that's very
festive well you guys are really
something else over there anyway uh
here's best and worst of VC at the exact
same time he opens up guns blazing
laying out truth clear clean Hest this
is good VC enjoy I think there's
something deeper going on in the
Republican party here and I am upset
about what happened last night we've
become a party of losers at the end of
the day was a cancer in the Republican
establishment
let speak the truth I mean since Ron
McDaniel took over as chairwoman of the
RNC in 2017 we have lost 2018 20120 2022
no red wave that never came we got
trounced last night in 2023 and I think
that we have to have accountability in
our party for that matter Ron if you
want to come on stage tonight you want
to look the GOP voters in the eye and
tell them you resign I will turn over my
yield my time to you and frankly look
the people there are cheering for losing
in the Republican Party think about
who's moderating this debate this should
be Tucker Carlson Joe Rogan and Elon
Musk we'd have 10 times the viewership
asking questions that GOP Primary voters
actually care about and bringing more
people into our party you think the
Democrats I we got Christian weler here
do you think the Democrats would
actually hire Greg Gutfeld to host a
democratic debate they wouldn't do it
and so the fact of the matters I mean
Krist I'm going to use this time because
this is actually about you in the media
and the corrupt media establishment ask
you the Trump Russia collusion hoax that
you pushed on this network for years was
that real or was that Hillary Clinton
made up disinformation answer the
question go Mr
Rob this is how we get our country
back that's good be that's good be I've
got some frustrations with him but
that's good be you know he hit a couple
things there first off on the Ron
McDaniel thing so R McDaniel she is the
head of the RNC the RNC which just well
the Republican party which just got
trounced yesterday in these elections
Virginia Kentucky couple other places
right the only bright spot of it for
Republicans yesterday was Long Island
where I'm from but that was about it uh
when Rona McDaniel came out at the
beginning this is not what you saw on
television so they they have a few
people come out and obviously they do
the national anthem Stars stripes and
all that kind of stuff but when she came
out and they announced and here she is
RNC chairwoman Ron McDaniel like the
crowd was not into it was not into it
and she just sounded so flat cuz she has
led to as VC pointed out a whole bunch
of losses for Republicans ironically
Donald Trump backed R McDaniel remember
what was it less than a year ago when
there was a fight for the head of the
RNC and the one uh that he did not back
the woman that he did not back was harit
Dylan who I had on the show this morning
uh who is liked more by the Bas it's one
of those weird politics makes strange
bedfellow things uh Ronda santis backed
harmy Dylan but we got R and she ain't
so great so that's good VC for sure then
he goes after the moderators and makes a
great point of saying that the the
Democrats would never allow a bunch of
Fox News moderators to moderate their
debate right Greg Gutfeld Etc none of
those guys would ever be asked and then
he goes even further with this stuff
about Russia collusion and everything
else just hit hit hit hit hit all good
VC that's the VC we want right and it's
a you know there's a little bit of like
a prick move on there he turns it on her
at the end but that's just fine that's
just fine and we need a little of that
zaz of that magic right that's what
Trump ran on the first time around that
that got him there but then VC does this
weird thing he has everyone in the room
with him you can feel it in the room
everyone's like whoa is this actually
happening and then the guy who says that
he's not the politician they're all
politicians they all have scripted lines
he just Wings it off the cup off the
cuff then he drops this one and Joe
Biden sold off our foreign policy Joe
Biden's son Hunter Biden got a $5
million bribe from Ukraine that's why
we're sending $200 billion back to that
same country the fact of the matter is
the Republican party is not that much
better you have the likes of Nikki Haley
who stepped down from her time at the UN
bankrupt or in debt is was her family
then she becomes a military contractor
she joins the board of Boeing and
otherwise and is now a multi-millionaire
so I think that that's wrong when
Republicans Do It Or democrats do it
that's the choice we face do you want a
leader from a different generation who's
going to put this country first or do
you want Dick Cheney and 3-in heels
which case we've got two of them on
stage
like you can feel it like people are
just not into it you can criticize Nikki
all you want you can say she did this
that or the other thing or whatever but
like that stuff when he's the same guy
who says oh we shouldn't have these
scripted insults we shouldn't insult
each other right let's do Reagan's 11th
Amendment thing and let's make sure that
we're Republicans not going after each
other it just kind of Falls flat I just
don't think it works and that that seems
to be the very very Hit or Miss thing
with him uh the other thing that's weird
about him is the Trump people seem to
love him right the Trump people hate Des
santis but they love him but the Trump
people are only allowed to love who
Trump wants them to love so it's like is
he really running for president or is he
running to either be in Trump's cabinet
or for some other thing I think that's
it's just something worth thinking about
right it's something worth worth
thinking about uh but let's move over to
Nikki for a second because he was going
after Nikki there uh here she is with
the jab on VC and then well I'll let you
decide on on whether you agree with her
far policy or not I am Telling You Putin
and president shei are salivating at the
thought that someone like that could
become president they would love to the
fact of the matter is she doesn't answer
this what I will tell you we're driving
Russia into
China had your time to talk the
Ambassador has the floor Ambassador the
first thing I'll tell you is we all
remember what that Thug did when he
invaded Ukraine we all know that half a
million people have died died because of
Putin and here is a freedom loving
pro-american country that is fighting
for its survival and its democracy no I
don't think we should give them cash I
think we should give them the equipment
the ammunition to win all right first
off let me just hit Nikki a little bit
there because the idea that Ukraine is
freedom loving pro-american I mean we
don't we have been giving them cash like
it's very unclear what's going on there
I think there is a massive and very easy
argument to be made about how the
Ukraine thing and the Israel thing
really have absolutely nothing to do
with each other and they should be
completely decoupled it's a damn shame
that the Biden Administration is trying
to tie those funding things together
they just have nothing to do with each
other um at that you know it's
interesting right now because there's
something happening in the Republican
party which is why I wanted to show you
this clip up top which is on one hand VC
represents more of the Trump side of
things which is the isolationist part
and all that and I am extremely
sympathetic to that argument right like
we shouldn't be getting and all these
adventurous Wars you've heard me talking
about Ukraine for a year right that's
different than helping a complete Ally
defend themselves not putting troops in
the Middle East but helping them
actually defend themselves as Israel in
this case of course after they've gone
through such an unbelievably horrific
attack but let's put that aside because
that's not what they were talking about
specifically there the the Ukraine thing
is much much more muddled and we have
been giving them cash and as Rand Paul
talks about we never get receipts or
anything else that doesn't mean that
doing nothing is right and we just have
to acknowledge that like you could be
the total isolationist the total
libertarian here and just want American
America have no involvement in anything
that doesn't necessarily mean the bad
guys don't keep marching right ask uh
Neville Chamberlain what happened when
he tried to appease the Nazis like if we
just are like all right Russia you just
take Ukraine all right we might have a
bigger problem on our hands I'm not
saying that that means you just go in
and do whatever the hell zalinsky wants
but this seems to be a tension that the
Republican party is happing right now I
would say it's actually a a healthy
tension that there are two wings of the
party saying boy we we're Republicans
whatever whatever that means right we're
Republicans but we really see foreign
policy difference so if you can have
that debate in an honest fashion without
insulting everybody and that's why the
3-inch heels thing was just kind of
ridiculous it's like then there's
something to be said uh anyway the Nikki
VC uh fireworks continued I just saw
this one in the car uh I guess they were
talking about Tick Tock uh you know I'm
no fan of Tik Tock I do not have Tik
tock on my phone I did not even want to
have Tik tock on have anything to do
with what we're doing here and then I
bring on Brock and he says I will put
the Tik tock on my phone so we could be
on there it's his call on that one if he
ever told me he didn't want to be on
there that would be fine too for the
show obviously anyway they got into it
on Tik Tok about Tik Tok and uh watch
this laugh at why Nikki Haley didn't
answer your question which is about
looking at families in the eye in the
last debate she made fun of me for
actually joining Tik Tok while her own
daughter was actually using the app for
a long time so you might want to take
care of your family first preaching
adult daughter the next generation of
Americans are using it and that's
actually the point you have her
supporters crapping her up that's fine
here's the truth the easy answer
is you're just scum I think we got to
loosen it up we got to loosen up the
program now once the word scum has been
invol invoked in a republican debate
look uh the Tik Tock thing is very
complex we we talked about this at the
last debate right are we starting an
only fans right now what the hell's
going on over here different show
um the Tik Tok thing is extremely
complex because there is an argument to
be made and Brock and I were discussing
this in the car on the way back that
young people are on Tik Tok you don't
want to consistently lose elections you
got to go to where young people are this
is an argument that V has made and and
it would be nice if you could affect
these people on the on the apps that
they're on right that is one argument
for it I understand that argument uh the
problem is that we all know that Tik Tok
is Chinese spyware and not only is it
Chinese spyware where they show uh
certain stuff to the people of China the
young people of China who get math and
science and physics and they learn on
Tik Tok while they break the brains of
our young kids right with through
algorithmic manipulation everything else
but we know even just in the last few
weeks that the amount of pro- Hamas
propaganda is 15x the pro-israel stuff
on Tik Tok because the algorithm is
feeding it because China is going boy
this is a pretty good way of going after
America we can get young people in
America to be protesting their
government and screaming for a ceasefire
and and yelling and hanging about a
whole bunch of stuff they know nothing
about just through our algorithmic stuff
because they're all walking around with
one of these in their pocket uh so it's
a debate worth having I I it would
probably be best for all Freedom loving
people if Tik Tok just disappeared
tomorrow uh but yes that again that was
another one of those things where on one
hand the is like kind of right about Tik
Tock then he brings up Nikki's daughter
that she I guess was on Tik Tok she
isn't anymore but once you open up the
door of talking about people's kids then
you're going to get called scum so there
you go all right let's roll through what
else happened again we are doing this on
the Fly uh DeSantis finally he chimed in
and and you know there's this
interesting thing with this antis where
in almost every I think in every debate
actually not almost every debate uh he
gets better as they go on he gets a
little he's a little tight up front he's
you know and and he is somewhat scripted
there's there's no doubt about it if you
want the most freewheeling like improv
I'm working the crowd comedian ever then
Dan santis is not your guy if that's
what you want if you want someone who
does what they say they're going to do
has a really good track record and the
rest of it then I think he is your guy
uh here uh is DeSantis and he doesn't
Spar that often right they don't go
after him that often and he doesn't go
after the other ones that often he just
basically lays out his case uh but Dan
santis and Nikki Haley did Spar a bit
over China a little bit ear brought a
fiberglass company 10 years ago to South
Carolina but Ron you are the chair of
your Economic Development agency that as
of last week said Florida is the ideal
place for Chinese businesses not only
that you have a company that is
manufacturer of Chinese military planes
you have it they are expanding two
training sites at two of your airports
now one which is 12 miles away from a
naval base then you have another company
that's expanding and they were just
invaded by the Department of Homeland
Security so mine was 10 years ago yours
was 6 months ago what's your story and I
abolish that agency that she's talking
about Enterprise Florida we abolish and
of course we baned China from buying not
exactly a great recruiting pitch if
you're Banning them from purchasing land
we stood up you know Ambassador Haley
said somehow I wasn't doing she welcomed
them into South Carolina gave them land
near a military base wrote the Chinese
Ambassador a love letter saying what a
great friend they were that was like
their number one way to to do economic
development in Florida I banned China
from buying land in this state and we
kicked out unties and we KCK the
confucious institutes out of our
universities we've recognized the threat
and we've acted swiftly and decisively s
Scott you so I think this is a pretty
weak line of attack from Nikki on Dan
santis because it is 100% true you can
check it yourself uh Florida has banned
the CCP has banned the government of
China from buying land in Florida
they've closed some other institutions
like nobody has done more on this so she
can say this that you're owner did this
it just doesn't apply I also just don't
think it's it's that much about uh it's
not it's not that connected to what
people are thinking about and the thing
is with the santis if you're going after
him you got to really try to get him on
something because people know that he's
a pretty good track record when it comes
to telling the truth uh speaking of
telling the truth I thought he really
did nail his response on Ukraine and how
you know maybe we've got some problems
at home and we should be reassessing
those instead of endlessly focusing on
that place halfway across the planet any
suggestion by zalinsky or anyone else
that we should that we're going to
eventually have US troops there I can
tell the American people when I'm
president that will not happen we are
not going to send your sons and
daughters to Ukraine I am going to send
troops to our Southern border if you
look at the threats that we Face
terrorists have come in through our
Southern border I'm going to shut it
down I'm going to have the military and
I'm going to deport the people who've
come particularly under Biden who've
come from the Middle East come from all
these places now Biden wants $105
billion uh most of that's Ukraine
including some of it going to pay
pensions for bureaucrats and salaries
that is a totally ridiculous use of
American tax dollars he says he has
money for border to try to do the media
repeat that when you look at it what
most of the money is is money to process
more illegal aliens into this country
how is that solving the problem that's
making the problem worse and what does
he do for the Indo Pacific a pittance
that is the top threat that we Face we
need to bring this war to an end we need
the Europeans to step up and do their
fair share and we need to get serious
about the top threat that this country
faces which is the Chinese Communist
party again that's Des santis at his
best right he's just laying it out yes
he is thought it all through he's
sticking to what he knows and he's
telling the truth we can't endlessly
fund this war in Ukraine that we don't
know what the high hell is going on that
we have no receipts on or anything else
how about instead of sending troops over
there or any more money over there we
send troops to defend our own border
that's pretty good and also that China
is actually the sort of bigger meta
enemy here and that is why he has banned
China from buying land here in the State
of Florida so that that's just good I
think that's I I don't pretend to tell
you to pretend that I don't have
opinions on this thing but I think that
that's like pretty empirically true that
that's just solid stuff uh the opening
question of the night was about Donald
Trump and Donald Trump not being there
and what uh what that means not only for
the debate but for the Republican party
and and really can any of these guys uh
deliver on some of that America First
stuff can you get magot to come over uh
here was desantis's answer on that now
if you look where we are now it's a lot
different than we were in 2016 and
Donald Trump's a lot different guy than
he was in 2016 he owes it to you to be
on this stage and explain why he should
get another chance he should explain why
he didn't have Mexico pay for the border
wall he should explain why he racked up
so much debt he should explain why he
didn't drain the swamp and he said
Republicans we're going to get tired of
winning well we saw last night I'm sick
of Republicans losing in Florida I
showed how it's done one year ago here
we want a historic Victory including a
massive Landslide right here in Miami
Dade County that's how we have to do it
yeah that that's the right answer you
know Republicans are losing across the
board everywhere since Trump became
president in 2016 Republicans in the
midterms what happened yesterday there's
just been a series of losses now you
could say those losses are because of
trump or you could say those losses have
nothing to do with Trump or anything
else but if Trump wasn't running right
now we we have one guy up there who is
modeling how to win how to change a
state completely demolish the Democrat
Party in the State of Florida and all of
the people who who you know supposedly
hate him at the moment the base that
hates him at the moment s months ago
eight months ago they all freaking love
the guy they all knew he was the best
governor in the state and everything
else and we would have I would say it
would be the most unified Republican
party uh probably since Ronald Reagan
reelection
1984 and until we kind of figure out
what to do with that uh this is this
this chaos is going to continue so look
I I said it as honestly as I could after
the last debate which was at the Reagan
library to me that Trump was the winner
of that one he won that debate by not
being there but I don't think Trump wins
tonight by not being there anymore I
think we are we are in too much of a
precarious Place The World Isn't just
you know it feels like it's just
spinning off its axis and it's not good
anymore Donald Trump for you not to be
there so there is one more debate is it
in Alabama is that what someone said to
me it's at the University of Alabama
it'll be next month we'll we'll see if
we can get there and and I know you
won't show up Donald Trump because you
believe that this strategy is working
and and just at the p tactical level you
might be right but it's not right for
America it's not you should stand up
there defend your ideas take the slings
if if the santimon is is such a sellout
and you're up by 50 points then then do
what's right for the country really
because because nobody really won
tonight Trump I said it I'm telling you
you can check last time I said Trump was
the winner last time by not being there
but he was not the winner this time Dan
santis is the is the winner basically
like he was the best most functional up
there again took no hits VC had his nice
moments but then also undercuts himself
Nikki it's like if you like Nikki you
just basically like Nikki and then
Christy and and Tim Scott did we even
play a Tim Scott clip is there even a
point we still don't know if we don't
know where his girlfriend is it's a lot
with this guy but the two of them it's
like that okay it's basically done with
them so then it's it's the other three
and I would say again the VC thing it's
just like all of the VC people at the
end of the day are going to vote for
Trump so he's not really there so it's
really Dan santis and Nikki and Trump
and we shall see this was a one more for
the good people I know what they want at
this hour okay look at you guys put some
pants on watching this program it's
disgusting what you're doing uh anyway
we will be back in the morning I want to
thank Connor and Phoenix and Brock for
working late tonight you guys want some
ice cream or something I'll see if I
have I'll see if I have some cookies or
something for you guys let's go back to
that blue look at that blue can we
change that on the Fly do you are you
have an ability you could change it
right now and let the people see let's
see what you can do let's see if we're
gonna see Conor is gonna see if he can
change the lights right now what can he
do what can we do don't if you give me a
rainbow
flag pissed what do you got here what
can we do let's see let's see anything
anything is anything oh oh oo that's
very synthwave you know I'm into the
synth wave very synth wave that's one
give me one more color change to excite
the people change change one of these oh
look at that anything can happen here at
the Ruben report it's it's Star Wars
lightsabers ladies and gentlemen we will
be back in the morning it's a uh it's a
Thursday which means it's a Ruben
report. locals.com Community Q&A so if
you want to get your questions in you
can submit them right now uh my full
interview with Eric Weinstein is up
across platforms and we've got a cold
close for you even though it's late it's
the evening we still were working hard
over here all right see you
[Music]
tomorrow are you
okay